deux ans et demi après la disparition
d'estelle mouzin à guermantes en
seine-et-marne la police essaie de
relancer son enquête pendant tout le
mois de juin une soixantaine de jeunes
victimes d'agressions ou de tentative
d'agression dans toute l'île de france
vont être entendus amaury guibert et à
la location
c'est depuis le début une enquête hors
norme
tout un village perquisitionné débattu
géante organisée 130 personnes placées
en garde à vue après la disparition
d'estelle mouzin le 9 janvier 2003 à
guermantes en seine-et-marne
les enquêteurs n'ont négligé aucune
piste aujourd'hui il se lance dans une
nouvelle opération d'envergure analyser
une soixantaine de dossiers d'agression
sexuelle de mineurs
de 2002 à 2005 en ile de france en tout
cas on sait qu'à certains enfants qui
ont signalé qu'ils avaient failli ou qui
avaient été abordés qui avait mis en
parallèle ce qui leur était arrivé avec
la disparition d'estelle
et je pense qu'en les mettant tous en
essayant d'exploiter toutes les
informations on pourra savoir retrouver
un indice qui mentent jusqu'à présent on
part des portraits robots qui ont été
établies dans le cadre de ces affaires
là puisque sur les affaires dans
lesquelles il n'y a pas de portrait
robot
on peut difficilement procéder à un
recoupement de liens toutes les
informations collectées seront rentrés
dans le système salvac c'est une base de
données qui permet de recouper
différentes affaires pour remonter
éventuellement un même criminel on a une
vision globale de l'ensemble des faits
commis sur le territoire national
contrairement à l'enquêteur qui va avoir
le nez dans le guidon et qui lui n'a pas
la possibilité de ces quartiers de son
dossier mais l'espoir reste mince de
relancer une enquête qui est au point
mort malgré deux ans et demi d'une
mobilisation menée sans relâche par les
proches des stèles